PROFESSOR: The students spend
about six hours in class
each week.
And right at the
beginning of the semester,
most of those six hours are
either lectures or activities
or workshops that
we have planned
to have inside the class.
It's very, very
tightly programmed.
This may involve, say,
brainstorming for the team
projects, or forming
up with teams,
going through the
project constraints,
or teaching them the techniques
that we want them to learn.
Near the end of the
semester, we heavily
scale back the program content.
We give students a
lot of class time
just to meet up with the teams.
Because for many,
many teams, it's
difficult enough to gather
six people in the same room,
in the same place,
at the same time.
To get eight of them
in the same room,
well, they're doing
it during class time.
At least you know everybody's
going to be there.
So we try to give as
much time as possible
later in the semester for
teams to actually work
on their project.
But sometimes that is planned
out, like playtest sessions,
for instance, where students
play each other's games.
PROFESSOR: In the first
half of the semesters,
all the lectures and workshops
are given by the staff.
But by the second
half of the semester,
we're getting them to see other
aspects of game development.
So within MIT
students-- and actually,
this year, a few Wellesley
students-- most of our students
are going to be coming to us
with a programming background.
A few might have some design
classes under their belt.
Maybe they've taken one
of our game design classes
or another design
class offered at MIT.
Some of the students are
going to have some art
aptitude, visual art aptitude.
Some, a little bit more a sound
design or music composition
aptitude.
But for the most
part, they don't know
what it's like to be an artist.
They don't know what it's
like to be a sound designer
on a game development project.
And they might actually
not know anything
about the business of games.
So the last half of the semester
is bringing in guest lecturers
from the industry.
We've got a great network here
in Boston, an independent game
developer network.
Also, quite a few of the
AAA larger studios are here.
So we mine our
network in each year.
We get new speakers
to come talk to them
about how to work
with an artist,
how to work with a sound
designer, what it actually
means to be an art
director in a game company,
or what actually does it
mean to even be a level
designer on a large project?
But then also, we're
bringing people in
to talk about business models.
Kickstarter is often
an interesting topic
for the students.
We try to balance
it between here's
what the industry
what looks like,
and here's the
things that are going
to help you, right now, with
the game that you're working on
now.
And if you wanted to take
the game a little bit further
after the course, here's the
things that you could do.
Things like fundraising,
submitting it to festivals,
marketing it, and just getting
other people to play it.